This is a story about failure, my failure.
And though the story
has some kind of a happy ending,
it's not your typical story where failure
is a stepping stone to success.
It almost feels like failure
is celebrated a lot these days.
For instance, you hear slogans like
"Fail forward, fail better, fail faster."
And to be honest,
these slogans drive me crazy.
I mean, who wants to fail?
Failure is not fun.
And I would know because, you know,
I'm sort of a poster child for failure.
In fact, when one of my friends
was writing a book about the topic,
he reached out to me
to write a chapter for his book.
But I'm also an educational designer,
so I see failure
in terms of systems and values.
That failure is often
a misalignment of values or bad design.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let me take you back
to this point of my failure.
So I want to take you back
to my undergraduate days,
my freshman year in engineering.
I'm sitting in a physics class.
I'm looking forward to learning.
And in my notes I'm writing
little limericks and poems
about quantum states.
That tells you something
about who I was when I was that age.
I loved physics and math,
but I also loved art and literature
and poetry and film.
And I was excited and engaged
to be in this engineering school.
Sadly, that was not the case.
Sadly, those next four years,
were possibly the worst
four years of my life.
Creativity and imagination
was not encouraged.
All we had was lectures upon lectures
and tests and tests and tests.
There was no scope for understanding.
There was no space
for having fun with the ideas.
And these poems I was writing,
they were, I'm sure, not great poetry,
but they were meaningful to me.
They were a way for me
to explore and play with ideas,
something that was squelched
very early on.
And so this went on for four years,
and I finally graduated.
But I never genuinely became an engineer.
I felt I was worthless, that I had failed.
And what was sad was
it was not a one-shot failure.
It was every day, every month,
semester after semester
for four long years.
And at this point, I saw a poster
for a program in visual communications,
and on a whim I decided to apply.
Clearly, I was not going to be
an engineer or a scientist,
so maybe, maybe
I could make educational film
because I had grown up inspired by people
like Carl Sagan and Jacob Bronowski.
Long story short, I got into the program,
and almost overnight my life changed.
The system and structure and culture
of the institution were very different.
Creativity was encouraged.
Flexibility and playing
with ideas was supported.
So even these things that I --
these haphazard things
that I had been interested in,
dabbling with art and science and poetry,
somehow were meaningful all of a sudden.
And it was also there that I was
introduced to the idea of design,
something I didn't know much about,
but I felt very much at home in.
For four years in engineering,
I had never felt
that I had become an engineer.
I had never felt like I belonged.
But somehow this design seemed
to give me a purpose and meaning.
And what was amazing was
how quick that change was.
You know, in May of that year,
I was feeling worthless,
as if I was a failure.
And by September of that same year,
I had found a purpose.
I had found a community.
I had found a field
that I could live within.
So even today, I call myself
an educational designer.
And what that made me realize
is that my success or failure depended
on a variety of systems and values
that were often hidden from me.
And this lens of design
then allowed me at look at the world
as something that had been made up.
And that made me question what are
the other things that we have made up.
Well, one of the biggest things
we have made up is this idea of school.
There is nothing natural
about schools and universities.
You know, there's nothing natural
about credit hours
and multiple choice exams and so on.
But underlying them are certain key values
about what is worth learning
and what is not.
So this has led me
to the work that I do today.
To design learner-centered,
just and equitable systems
that question these assumptions
that we have made
about how learning should and can happen.
Now, how does that work?
So let me give you a story.
A few years back,
a local school district reached out to us
to help them design
a school for the future.
Now that's a tall order.
What does that even mean?
How did we go about doing it?
Well, first we created a design team:
an eclectic collection
of teachers, administrators,
parents, members of the community.
And then we set out to listen.
So we talked to the chambers of commerce.
We created focus groups.
We talked to parent groups.
And most importantly, all through this,
we kept asking ourselves:
Who is at the table, and who is not?
And how could we bring those
who were not into the conversation?
For instance, one group
that we never talk to
or very rarely talk to are children,
which is very strange
given that they are the ones
who are going to actually
be in these schools.
So we talked to kids, lots of them.
We in fact followed them for a day.
You know, sitting in their classes,
listening to lectures, doing worksheets,
eating cafeteria food
and really enjoying the joy of recess.
And while we were doing this
and listening,
we kept asking ourselves questions.
What were we seeing? What does this mean?
And we began to question assumptions.
Like why are things a certain way?
How might we create a school
that actually connects with the community?
How might we think of technology in ways
that allow for expression and creativity?
How might we create a school
which is driven
by the impulses of the learner?
How might we create a school
where we break the "one teacher,
one classroom" model?
And in these conversations
we developed a set of design principles,
a set of values that would guide
our discussions and our design.
These were things
that as a community, we believed in.
And it was at this point in time
where things seemed to go a little slow,
where we had so many possibilities,
but yet they seemed like very few.
And we wondered what the next
step forward would be.
And there were all kinds
of the usual hassles of internet failures
and scheduling problems.
But then chance happened.
We learned about this building,
which was somewhat
unused in the school district
that they said we could play with,
and suddenly the whole
design team was energized.
And if there's a lesson here,
it is that you need to be prepared.
And if an opportunity comes your way,
you grab it with both hands
and don't let go.
And that's exactly what we did.
All the work we had done
with the focus groups
and the design principles and so on
came together in this school
and over two years of work later,
this school exists today.
It is a school that reflects
the values of the community.
It's a school that's very different
from the ones that you see around you.
We had to break down,
both literally and figuratively,
a whole bunch of walls
to create this space
where 100-plus kids
would learn and work together.
It is a space where they're surrounded
by an array of responsible adults
who work in teams,
working in small groups and large,
to meet the needs of these learners.
It is a school which is open
to the community,
both in its demographics,
as well as allowing parents
and community members
to go in and out as and when needed.
This is truly a special place.
And that doesn’t mean
that we have figured everything out.
But I’m proud to say
that that school is expanded.
It went in the next year
to another studio space,
and then now it goes
all the way from K through eight.
And for my team, this is truly
one of our greatest successes.
To circle back to the beginning.
You know, one could argue that it was
that failure that led to this success,
but I think that would
be missing the point.
It would be missing the point
because it ignores the pain
and hurt that failure causes.
It ignores the agony
that I went through for four long years.
At that point, when I graduated
from my undergraduate degree,
I felt I had failed,
I did not blame the system.
But now, when I look at it,
I realize maybe it was
a system that had failed me.
A system that fails a lot of our children.
Focusing on the individual
prevents us from looking deeper.
It prevents us from questioning
the systems that led to the failure.
It prevents us from questioning the values
that underlie these systems.
We can and must do better.
I think our children deserve better.
That 18-year-old me writing poetry
in physics class deserved better.
Thank you.